[Música]
[Aplausos]
muy buenas tardes quisiera pedirles
primero que miren detenidamente la
imagen que tengo detrás de mí en este
momento mientras comparto algo que
quisiera leer textualmente para mantener
la fidelidad miren de nuevo ese punto es
aquí es nuestro hogar somos nosotros en
él han vivido todos nuestros seres
queridos todos nuestros conocidos todos
de quienes hemos oído hablar todo ser
humano que ha existido la suma de
nuestras alegrías y sufrimientos miles
de religiones ideologías y doctrinas
económicas seguras de sí mismas
cazadores y recolectores héroes y
cobardes creadores y destructores la
civilización reyes y campesinos cada
joven pareja de enamorados cada padre y
madre cada hijo prometedor inventores y
exploradores maestros de moral políticos
corruptos cada superestrella y cada
líder supremo todos los santos y
pecadores de la historia de nuestra
especie vivieron aquí en ese grano de
polvo suspendido en un rayo
la tierra es un diminuto escenario en
una vasta arena cósmica piensa que los
ríos de sangre derramados por generales
y emperadores para gloriosa y
triunfalmente volverse por un momento
amos de esa fracción de ese punto
piensen en las interminables crueldades
ejercidas por los habitantes de un
rincón de ese píxel sobre los casi
indistinguibles habitantes de algún otro
rincón juan frecuentes sus pares
entendidos cuán dispuestos a matarse
unos a otros
cuán pendientes sus odios el texto que
cabe leer es de carl sagan un famoso
astrónomo estadounidense y termina si
nuestro planeta es una manchita
solitaria en la gran noche cósmica en
nuestra oscuridad en toda esta vastedad
no hay señal de que de alguna parte vaya
a llegar ayuda para salvarnos de
nosotros mismos
la idea de un apocalipsis creado por
nosotros mismos ha estado aumentando la
humanidad por mucho tiempo yo diría que
hay más o menos tres escenarios
principales que han sido más importante
en los últimos años el primero es una
hecatombe nuclear el de la posibilidad
de que efectivamente podamos
aniquilarnos y de hecho hemos ya
demostrado hace 70 años que tenemos un
gran poder destructivo con armas
atómicas el segundo escenario es
robocalypse algo así como que en el
mejor de los casos los robots nos quiten
los empleos nos reemplacen y en el peor
de los casos como las películas que
tomen el control de la humanidad y nos
sometan nos esclavizan y el tercero es
probablemente uno que ustedes han
escuchado mucho últimamente la
posibilidad de que la tierra sufra
demasiado la posibilidad de que de hecho
la raza humana se extinga en algún
momento estos tres escenarios han estado
atormentando no por mucho tiempo y
además de eso son
sumamente peligroso no por tanto como
escenario en sí ni tanto por sus
posibilidades sino por cómo intensifican
ciertos sentimientos en nosotros el
primero que se me ocurre me lo recuerda
este este personaje que están acá no sé
si han visto la película kingsman una
película una comedia de espías y hay un
villano que se llama richard valen time
este villano una especie de
ambientalista radical que tiene un
proyecto y de batería su teoría es que
el calentamiento global es el virus este
adorno es el es la fiebre del planeta y
que nosotros seres humanos somos el
virus y que nosotros seres humanos
siendo el virus
tenemos que ser destruido
eso parece ficción y de hecho es ficción
pero esta reflexión hace un tiempo atrás
en los años 90 existía en eeuu una
llamada iglesia de la eutanasia y decía
y perdonen la crudeza con la que lo voy
a decir pero voy a traducir exactamente
salva la tierra
suicídate ese era el lema que tenían
hace los tiempos atrás y sigue mucha
gente pensando que son unos monstruos
eso se llama misantropía lo contrae la
filantropía la filantropía es el amor
por las personas el amor puede ser
humano en la misantropía es el desprecio
por el género humano
el otro sentimiento lo
resumo con estas dos notas que están acá
una apareció en la tercera aunque el
chileno hace muy pocos días y la otra
apareció una revista internacional y muy
famosa que se dice en varios idiomas y
el primero entrevista en los niños
entrevistan unos 20 niños más o menos si
no me equivoco y les preguntan cómo han
recibido todas estas cosas que están
pasando por el medio ambiente con el
cambio climático con la crisis climática
y dicen cosas como por ejemplo es
parecido como cuando mataron a jesús se
iban a empezar a morir todos no puedo
dormir niños con lo que llaman eco
ansiedad pánico pavor mucha angustia y
en el otro la otra noticia ven ustedes
en la revista vice como persona están
tan deprimida que no solamente piensa
sino que de hecho llegan a quitarse la
vida ese sentimiento no es simplemente
miedo es realmente pánico esa angustia
esa ansiedad al más alto nivel
el problema es todo sentimientos que son
tremendamente peligrosos para el ser
humano el primero porque nos anula y es
autodestructivo el pensar que somos unos
monstruos que son una plaga del universo
que son una plaga en la tierra realmente
nos crea un serio problema el desprecio
hacia nosotros mismos el segundo es un
problema mucho muy distinto pero que
también nos produce ansiedad que también
nos produce la posibilidad de que
cometamos grandes errores la posibilidad
de que nos lleve incluso a la parálisis
y que no podamos actuar correctamente
así que lo que les propongo yo hoy aquí
es un cambio de perspectiva muy radical
y ese cambio de perspectiva pasa por
mirar la foto una forma distinta esta
foto fue tomada a 6.4 mil millones de
kilómetros de la tierra en el espacio
carl sagan fue el que pidió que tomaran
esa foto en un momento cuando una de las
de los dispositivos que estaban en el
espacio pidió que lo giran hacia la
tierra para tomar ese punto azul pálido
como le llamo y eso habla mucho de las
capacidades que tenemos los seres
humanos y que la primera idea que les
quiero proponer es que pese a nuestros
temores incluso pese a las
probabilidades de que alguno de estos
escenarios sea real nunca hemos estado
en tan buenos tiempos como hoy lo típico
en estos casos y mostrar este tipo de
gráficos como somos más ricos o
demostrar que este otro estos otros
casos como somos mucho menos pobres como
incluso cumplimos las metas del milenio
en materia de pobres de reducción de la
pobreza extrema en tiempo récord
sin embargo yo quisiera mostrarle sus té
de una forma distinta también de ver
este asunto y parte con la pregunta de
cómo llegamos a donde estamos y cómo
llegamos desde acá porque nosotros
nuestros ancestros hace mucho tiempo
atrás no sabía ni siquiera hacer algo
tan simple y común como el fuego algo
que es tan simple para nosotros hoy cómo
encender una cerilla y estamos no
solamente creando grandes cosas creando
inteligencia artificial yendo al espacio
a conquistarlo pensando en la
posibilidad realmente de asentarnos en
otro planeta y de ficción
ahora como hemos llegado a esto si uno
mira la historia la humanidad se divide
básicamente en cuatro grandes momentos
un primer momento cuando descubrimos el
fuego y el lenguaje o cuando lo
inventamos mejor el fuego lo cubrimos
pero el lenguaje que inventamos no
sabíamos hablar no sabíamos comunicarnos
como lo hacemos hoy hoy en fuera como ya
tremenda con whatsapp en varios idiomas
que señor o emoticones
después creamos las ciudades la
agricultura esto nos permitió aceptarnos
esto nos permitió dejar de corretear
mahmood y estar tomando manzanas por ahí
y después creamos otras cosas más la
escritura el dinero la imprenta etcétera
etcétera
el momento en el que nos encontramos hoy
es un momento sumamente crucial para la
historia humanidad porque es cuando
hemos empezado a crear la inteligencia
artificial a desarrollarla a pasos muy
acelerados y a utilizarlas para
incrementar nuestras capacidades
esta era que vivimos es la era de mayor
prosperidad de toda la historia de la
humanidad y no es porque son más ricos
es porque tenemos la mayor acumulación
de soluciones para la vida humana todo
lo que nos rodea son grandes soluciones
para la vida humana y esto me dice
favorito la expectativa de vida tienen
que pasar demasiadas cosas buenas para
que seamos capaces de duplicar la
expectativa de vida en cuestión de menos
de dos siglos pasar de los 40 años a
mediados del siglo 19 a los 70 y tanto y
80 en algunos casos hoy eso significa
menos guerra pero significa más paz
mejor alimentación mejor salud aquí hay
un ejercicio que hace unos científicos
donde recogen varios inventos varias
cosas ver descubrimientos pero sobre
todo en el área de la salud por ejemplo
carl einstein él descubrió los grupos
sanguíneos sólo eso se calcula más o
menos se calcula más o menos que ha
salvado unos mil millones de vidas la
suma de todos los científicos y los
descubrimientos que ellos han estudiado
en este proyecto se calcula o se estima
que han salvado más o menos unos cinco
mil millones de vidas más o menos
70% de la humanidad oye el equivalente
al 70% la humanidad hoy me atrevo a
decir sin ánimo exagerar que somos una
especie de súper humano no a lo marvel
somos super humanos porque tenemos hoy
capacidades que nuestros ancestros
atribuida a dioses volar a respirar bajo
el agua hacer tantas cosas que podemos
hacer hoy que son incluso para algunos
casi milagrosa tenemos una capacidad
impresionante de impacto en nuestro
entorno de transformación del entorno
para bien a veces para mal
hemos iluminado la cara la tierra como
se ve en esta foto de noche de la nasa
con las luces de las ciudades somos
capaces de transformarnos nosotros
mismos de implantar los chips de acero
soviético somos capaces de imprimir un
corazón con todos sus ventrículos sus
vasos sus cámaras y con adn humano en
prueba
que promete que algún momento va a
salvar vidas humanas
la segunda idea que quiero plantearles
es que llevamos siglos resolviendo los
más desafiantes problemas con
inteligencia creatividad que tienen como
estas tres cosas anteojos la
pasteurización y weiss los anteojos nos
ayudan a ver mejor con realidad mental
va a ayudar más también la
pasteurización nos ayuda por ejemplo a
tomar leche 500 secarnos por varios días
y weiss nos ayuda a ser conductores
expertos en ciudad que ni siquiera
conocemos con un tráfico más eficiente y
armas rápido las cosas que no que tiene
en común estas tres cosas que son
tecnologías no son tecnologías así
pensando simplemente los chips pantallas
táctiles todas estas cosas son
tecnologías porque es una aplicación de
la inteligencia y el conocimiento a las
soluciones de nuestros problemas y
además de eso y además de eso son el
incremento de nuestras capacidades la
primera de las máquinas son ayudó a
superar nuestra capacidad física con
muchas de nuestra capacidades físicas
volar correr alzar peso
y la de nuestros animales también pero
las de ahora las máquinas de esta era
nos está ayudando a superar muchas de
nuestras limitaciones cognitivas las de
nuestro cerebro eso nos da miedo
tremendo a muchos porque decir bueno y
nos van a reemplazar como esta portada
de la revista y york era hace un tiempo
atrás de dos años más o menos
exactamente dos años donde se entró
votando la limosna a las personas pero
las máquinas no vinieron para
reemplazarlo de hecho porque no vinieron
las creamos nosotros las máquinas las
hemos creado para incrementar nuestras
capacidades y no como en el caso esta
foto que usted haga quizás esto
solamente se da en países desarrollados
en entornos con mucho dinero mucha
prosperidad no es como el caso estos
campesinos que puede usar su smartphone
para encontró las cosechas para saber
con big data una cantidad de cosas que
los ni siquiera las grandes
corporaciones podrían manejar hace un
tiempo atrás así que tenemos resolviendo
siglos grandísimos problemas alimentar a
gran parte de la humanidad salvar vidas
a gran escala es una cuestión que hemos
venido haciendo con tecnología reciclar
por ejemplo una tecnología la 3a idea
que quiero mostrarles es que hemos
demostrado además que todo esto lo
podemos utilizar para hacer el bien no
para poner bombas atómicas y hacer
guerra en estas cosas además para hacer
el bien que tiene en común estos tres
personajes que ven detrás de mí el ibi
el bill gates y bojan es la 'libia' es
un israelí que creó una cuestión que se
llama united hat salvaje como el power
de la ambulancia es capaz escapar y que
escuchen esto muy bien es capaz de
atender emergencias en tres minutos con
el 90 segundos es un país donde puede
ver desde un atentado terrorista hasta
un accidente de tránsito o un infarto y
lo más bonito de todo esto es que lo
hace juntando voluntarios de todas las
religiones judíos musulmanes rusos
cristianos árabes salvando judíos judíos
amando árabe
con alta tecnología sistema de
posicionamiento global teléfono
smartphone ambulancia motocicleta
el segundo bill gates que no solamente
ha cambiado gran parte del mundo con
microsoft durante muchos años sino que
ahora se dedica con belinda gates en una
fundación a llevar salud a hierba cura
investigar sobre el medicamento y
tenemos a boy aislado que es un joven de
25 años que se ha dedicado a la
impresionante tarea de tratar de borrar
la mancha de plástico el pacífico que
tiene más o menos el tamaño de dos veces
texas
pretende para el año 2040 con todo ha
tenido altibajos éxito o fracaso hay un
montón de cosas pero pretende poder más
o menos hacer lograr esto en un 90 por
ciento haciendo que el 40 y utiliza este
sistema que se llama wilson con
satélites con sensores con una cante de
cosas y es capaz de recoger grandes
cantidades de plástico y esto lo podemos
hacer todos a todas las escalas lo
hicimos en el terremoto el 2010 acá en
chile activamos una cantidad de
cooperación y de voluntariado de cosas
para salvar vidas para para crear bien y
hacerle bien a la sociedad
todo esto que les estoy contando no es
un ejercicio simplemente ingenuo de ver
el vaso medio lleno o medio vacío sino
de cómo podría estar el vaso por lo que
lo que hemos demostrado en estos pasos
que están acá es todo lo que nosotros
podemos hacer podemos hacer mal y
podemos hacer mucho bien pueden salir
las cosas más efectivamente pero mañana
es hasta la tercera guerra mundial y
crear un gran desastre pero es por eso
que el gran reto de hoy no está en parar
el progreso no está porque no hay botón
de pánico no hay un auto el delorean que
nos lleve al pasado no imagina el tiempo
nada de eso y el costo de parar el
progreso es altísimo y además que nos
priva o nos privaría de muchísimas cosas
buena el gran desafío de hoy tiene que
ver con lo que le mencioné hace un
momento atrás con esta idea de los súper
humanos
porque si somos super humanos tenemos
una especie de súper poderes en una
película de spider-man el tío baileys a
peter parker spider man le dice un gran
poder viene con una gran responsabilidad
y eso me recordó mucho al presidente
checo vaclav hável cuando el año 1995 en
harvard dijo de un discurso donde habló
de una renovación radical de sentido de
responsabilidad
yo quisiera dar acá tres puntos para
terminar en como yo veo esta radical
renovación del sentido de retratar y
responsabilidad la primera es entender
el progreso tal como es de seres humanos
imperfectos no es un camino de ascenso
alineadas el paraíso porque el paraíso
demás no existe
es constantemente desafiante lo que hace
el progreso con nosotros es ayudarnos a
resolver muchos problemas en la medida
en que aparecen otros el precio tiene un
costo que tiene muchísimos beneficios y
lo que hemos ido haciendo en el tiempo
es lidiar con eso es después cuando
aparecen nuevos problemas tratar de
sobre esos nuevos problemas es
permanentemente desafiante y desafiante
para nuestro cerebro desafiante para
nuestros valores la segunda cosa es
valorar nos mucho más esta idea de la
misantropía es sumamente peligrosa
porque la misantropía nos ayuda no
perdón nos dos a lula y de hecho nos
ayuda tanto que dejamos de ser parte de
la solución a los problemas valorarnos
más es el segundo gran desafío que
tenemos hoy de valorar más las
capacidades que tenemos y el tercero es
no intentar vencer el miedo es manejar
el bien lo calibrarlo ponderar lo ni
siquiera los más fuertes soldados de
élite en el mundo se les enseña a
eliminar el miedo oa no tener miedo
crisparon todo explica en su libro en su
memoria de cuando estuvo en libia hace
un tiempo de transición es real
extrema el miedo no hay que tratar de
evitarlo perdemos el tiempo es un gran
aliado cuando lo manejamos bien porque
nos advierte los riesgos nos advierte
los peligros y nos ayuda efectivamente a
veces a no ser suicidas
así que me despido con esta imagen y
quiero cerrar solamente con lo último
que dice carl sagan en este extracto muy
interesante dice quizás no existe una
mejor demostración de la desmesura de
las presunciones humanas que esta imagen
distante de nuestro pequeño mundo para
mí subraya nuestra responsabilidad de
tratarnos entre nosotros con mayor
bondad y de preservar y apreciar este
palio punto azul el único hogar que
hemos conocido muchas gracias
[Música]